la polémique autour de kanata a fait
fuir des co producteurs nord-américains
et faute d'argent
kanata n'aura pas lieu un scandale selon
yves jacques
un ami de robert lepage je pense que la
communauté noire et autochtone de
montréal ont tiré sur leurs messages et
leurs meilleurs messagers mondial et
j'ai beaucoup de jeu de l'émotion parce
que ça me fait de la peine de voir un
grand artiste comme comme lepage se
faire assassiner de la sorte
cette annulation survient moins de trois
semaines après une autre annulation
celle de slave un spectacle également
signé par robert lepage et qui a semé la
controverse
je suis profondément choqué de ces
choses là parce que forcément elle le
théâtre c2c devenir quelqu'un d'autre
par voie de communiqué la compagnie ex
machina écrit et je cite au delà de
cette troublante situation il nous
faudra bien tôt ou tard tenter de
comprendre calmement et ensemble ce que
sont fondamentalement l'appropriation
culturelle et le droit à une expression
artistique libre le collectif de
signataires autochtone qui a lancé le
débat avec une lettre ouverte se dit
attristée de l'annulation je veux bien
faire comprendre aux gens à la maison
que si le spectacle est annulé
et bien si par manque de fonds
monétaires et c'est pas à cause de
quelques autochtones enragé cette
décision survient une semaine après une
rencontre à huis clos entre 35 membres
de la communauté autochtone et les
créateurs de kanata robert lepage et
ariane mnouchkine
une participante à cette rencontre
affirme que l'annulation du spectacle
est une bonne décision parce que c'est
une bonne nouvelle si on n'inclut pas
les premières nations et se contente de
réel devrait continuer action je ne
crois pas je ne crois pas en réaction à
l'annulation de kanata les réseaux
sociaux s'enflamme et certains crient à
la censure
la coalition avenir québec affirme que
c'est une autre décision regrettable
le chef du parti québécois dit que c'est
un recul intolérable de la liberté
artistique
la ministre de la culture du québec
écrit que cette annulation est
malheureuse et que personne n'y gagne
yves jacques lui se pose la question
suivante
alors moi j'ai une grosse question je
vais jouer le ferai ma vie
dorel prochainement j'ai commencé j'ai
deux jours de tournage
est ce que j'ai le droit de jouer le
frère marie-victorin parce que je suis
homosexuel et non croyants
est ce que la communauté religieuse de
montréal va m'empêcher de jouer
ou est-ce qu'on a un disque est ce que
c'est le retour du duplessisme le
théâtre du soleil devait présenter
kanata à paris en décembre 2018
ariane mnouchkine et robert lepage ont
décliné nos demandes d'entrevue ici
louis philippe ouimet radio canada
montréal